as humans we go through so many ups and
downs so many good seasons bad seasons
and today Justin opens up like never
before revealing a secret battle with
Lyme disease following reports that he
would reveal his diagnosis in his
upcoming YouTube docu-series seasons the
singer confirmed the news on Instagram
and adds not only that but had a serious
case of chronic mono which affected my
skin brain function energy and overall
health back in September the singer
spoke at length about his mental health
on Instagram saying at one point he felt
like a shell of a person he was spotted
leaving a medical building in LA wearing
an IV drip that same month and in
October cameras spotted him getting in a
car looking visibly emotional in today's
post he continues it's been a rough
couple years but getting the right
treatment that will help treat this so
far incurable disease and that will be
back and better than ever
when you're doing what you are good at
you just feel like here you're supposed
to be justin joins a list of celebs who
successfully manage the disease
including Shania Twain Avril Lavigne and
Bella and Yolanda Hadid